the most important thing is to
understand that nobody is really going
to win here it's completely different
than the single member district system
that you have in the UK there are no
safe seats parties are running up and
down the country they're trying to get
as many votes as they can wherever they
can and we add this all together at
whatever percentage of the national vote
a party gets that's exactly the
percentage of seats it will get the two
largest parties are at about twenty
percent in the polls which means they'd
be declared losers in a British election
they're going to win the election here
so the name of the game is not so much
who gets more seats but who can actually
form that majority after the elections
the Israeli voter does coalition
building in the voting booth in other
words if you're very hard right you will
not vote just for the Likud Party but
you will vote for a more hard right hard
II hoping that they will be needed in
the majority coalition and you can drag
Likud more to the right